[Music]
hallelu look who's here
miss shangela is in the house yes
hallelu I'm back again back again I'm
Rui sander welcome back to et and
welcome back to you you are a movie star
now oh stop no please tell me one more
time in a small independent picture that
maybe a few people saw to the tune of
what forty two point six million dollars
opening weekend a star is born is out
yes you are in it we're gonna get all
into that on to what you've got going on
going on almost a two hundred city to or
this one yeah and stop she's a
professional but while we get people in
here to watch and comment and send in
your questions let's take a look at a
clip from the film your big-screen debut
let's do it check it out let me close
this bar please don't talk to me like
that in that bus driver weird girl oh I
know you did not wish you have a Street
appointment tonight mister main would
you mind I showed you mine you show me
yours come on show us all the good
because you you already performs
yes son nice thank you the man is a li
not for you sister she's nice in the
cute light did you do this yourself yep
ami it was great
this mic work oh yeah what you only have
playing I don't care just look at me
while you're doing I mean those were
some of the biggest laughs in that movie
cuz it's not a comedy but the last
common that those early scenes with you
guys
yes we had so much fun doing it I'm
telling you I can only imagine you and
Willem together on that set and you guys
you auditioned independently it wasn't
like a package deal of oh we're going
out and grabbing these Ruger rolls to
come to this movie this was an acting
gig you booked walk me through that
process of how oh yeah well I'm looking
back at that now it just makes me feel
like so happy that it was cast away that
it was because Willem and I have worked
together in hurricane Bianca one the
film we've toured together so a lot of
the chemistry between the two of us felt
very natural back when we auditioned
originally you know the original casting
call was for a drag queen Marilyn Monroe
type impersonate I think he also had
like a little zombie element to it it
was something injured you know how roles
roles will evolve but that was the
initial casting so I didn't go in for
the role and I remember my agent asked
you know I was like honey
it does not matter how much time I spend
out of the Sun I ain't gonna look like
Marilyn Monroe and if they're going spot
on Marilyn it's just not gonna be my gig
but then I got an email from Lady Gaga's
camp and they were like LG really wants
wants to know it said LG Lady Gaga heard
that you didn't come in for the film to
audition and she really wanted you to
come in for this film she feels like you
would be a good fit for one of the roles
why are you not coming in and I was like
oh honey hold on I found the nearest
blonde wig and the nearest white dress
and I went in there honey and gave them
a little merit black Marilyn I was black
Marilyn and ultimately I didn't get that
role it was a drag queen lip-sync only
role but they liked my personality so
much an LG believed in me they gave me a
larger role that actually a dialogue and
was the bar owner so I was very happy to
be able to go in for that pretty wild
though crazy even an email from Lady
Gaga being like why don't you show up
for my movie well Lady Gaga's camp yes
it was a third party communication but
you guys have a little history you were
in the applause video
yeah back what was that like
2013 okay why five years ago yeah
through my friend Perry meek who was
working with Gaga at the time as a
wardrobe stylist Perry said he sent me a
message said hunted the lady that's Lady
Gaga gives a lot of names thirty Gaga
the lady has requested that you appear
in her video that tonight that she's
gonna be in West Hollywood for and honey
I put the art pop makeup I was the day
to come out so I had to literally lyrics
yes if anyone goes to my YouTube page
you'll see I'd like to film the whole
process we were going it's my first a
living with shangela episode called oh
my gah gah and I was getting ready
trying to listen to the music at the
same time first during this like art pop
you know the look with the smeared and
when we got there I remember thinking ok
I want to turn it up for Gaga but you
know how it is when you go on stage and
it's just lights all I saw were lights
and dark audience right but I saw blonde
in there to the right and I was like you
know blowing kisses over there like hey
Gaga girl in the middle of the thing I
realize the camera the people in the
audience were filming the cameraman with
their phones I'm like what it I'm up
there I turned gaga was the camera and
she filmed that video yeah he had the
brown hair not the blonde so now I'm
like oh my god let me bow down for the
Gaga I never get a booking again but
luckily she was very kind we're
backstage was so nice and then fast
forward 4 years to this and she still
remembered me and thought you know what
let's let's get Shane over here so
things happen for a reason out there so
walk me through the filming process you
guys film this a year ago right yes back
in May well these scenes were filmed
back in April May of 2017 okay and how
long did it take to film your scenes
only a couple days really we were on set
probably a couple days but it felt like
we were there so much longer because it
was so much fun honestly I didn't want
to leave at all I was like can this be
like summer vacation got nothing to do
right I was like she did but it was
really great you know as much of a
professional that she and Bradley truly
are I just remember it them creating
such a set that was really laid back and
fun and everyone felt comfortable being
themselves and also doing their best
work favorite memory from filming
adding chatting between the scenes you
know they would like be like okay cut
you know we have to turn the cameras
around that takes a little time and Gaga
you know could have just gotten our
trailer and waited but she was so cool
like she was like okay Shannon let's so
she was sitting in the dresser was me
her couple people from her team Richie
and and Fred Roggin people and so I
would you know I was like oh honey I'm a
jester at the court let me let me talk
to the Queen and I just started like
telling her some fun stories and like
just being loose and having a good time
to see if she and she was so much like
that as well she started laughing haha
Chad you know called me Shann so that
was really cute like she was so warm you
talked her for thirty seconds you're
like this is my home girl I love her so
are you home girls now like you have her
phone number in your phone I don't have
her number however I feel in my head
that she could call me at any time now I
will say that in London where we saw
each other for the first time since the
film on the red carpet and she looked
beautiful she was in the you know the
Alexander McQueen Shakespearean goddess
and I was in my goal with the sleeve you
actually have look at you girl you look
good girl that's what I was standing at
Diego Montoya game I'm wearing yes
so I remember she looked at me before we
even got to speak there she's walking
past like she's holding the skirt she
just mailed to me work it girl oh and I
was like oh so cute
and then afterwards after we saw the
film and at the Soho House where they
had kind of like the private little
after-party thing look at me
you know what the so about the London
darling I was there with Gaga inhale so
I'm in there and I go over to it I'm
just like Lady gaga I just wanted to say
thank you again so much for you know
give me this opportunity and she's like
no shangela tonight when I saw you I was
like there's a star and I'm like oh my
god thank you and I'm like you know what
okay would you mind meeting my mom cuz
she flew all the way from Texas I just
want to say hi if it's okay she was like
where's your mother and I point her she
goes across the room to my mom my mom's
dead she's like you must be Debra and
she gives her a big old hug and she's
like are you so proud of him she was so
nice it was like now my mom tells
everybody that Gaga is my best planner
like don't do that mama it's not true my
back
we have footage of you on that red
carpet in the UK looking phenomenal walk
me through what it was like to walk down
that red carpet and really have that
moment and soak all of that in you know
I say this a lot but it's so true I felt
like Cinderella at the ball I'm even
better I felt like you remember Drew
Barrymore in ever ever after what she
cause of she's like just breathe you
know yes that's what I had to tell
myself breathe mama you know it's hard
because I was in a corset and I was
snatched yet I want to be like
skin-tight bobbing chair you are yeah so
I thought that was really awesome and
cool and it was one of those moments
that I will remember I had to journal
about it because literally that night
after the red carpet after the film
after the Soho House I went and did a
gig over at GA Y high club in London
yeah 1:00 a.m. I took the stage honey I
love that place we did the show and then
literally I hopped a flight at 6:40 a.m.
to go to Atlanta to do a show the next
day so I had to like write in my journal
like remember these moments how it felt
how it was because I always want to
remember that what was the one thing you
made sure you wrote down there I
remember - oh how I rolled up on Bradley
Cooper and Lady gaga
and the look on their face at first cuz
I you know I was in the big hair of my
brows and everyone was going in to watch
the film because it was starting soon
but they had to go and film the Graham
Norton Show so after they took their
photos into their interviews they had to
leave and I was like no I need a picture
with them together I want to remember
that so they were like you can't I was
like oh honey I'm a drag queen watch
this and I swooped in there with my
little hair and as soon as they were
about to make their eggs I jumped up
from behind and Bradley was like hey but
he was so nice he was like have you seen
the movie have you seen the film yet I'm
like it's gonna be my first time he was
like oh you're good go check it out
you're gonna like it I'm like thank you
mr. Cooper Wow gah guy was so sweet like
it was awesome we got that picture honey
I got that picture you had to make sure
you got that yeah was there pressure for
that like oh I'm gonna make my debut I'm
now a movie star I don't call myself no
movie star okay well you should well
thank you very much it's a really I'm
just happy I didn't tell a lot of people
about it after filming because you never
know what's actually gonna make it into
the film Sarah and I was in a movie once
called RIPD I had a small role I was in
drag you know right I think it was Ryan
Gosling
anyhow I'm in the
right and at one point Jeff Bridges was
supposed to morph into me
shangela so afterwards when it came out
I told my mom ghosts the RIPD I'm on the
road but you go see it mom I'm in the
movie she called me up she was like baby
you ain't in that movie I said no mama
I'm in the movie she was like no baby
you're not in the movie so I now to see
it and see what an awesome part we had
in the film is really cool sitting in
that theater at the premiere and seeing
the reaction to you guys like I said
when I saw the movie those were the big
laughs big like crowd-pleasing moments
were in those drag bar scenes what was
it like to be in the room with people
watching you on a big screen it was
really special because my mom was there
too and that was you know that's the
first like big Hollywood movie that I've
ever been in and she was there with me
and but I was a little uncomfortable not
from the film but because I didn't have
a chance to change a giant hair in my
corset again I was a long film two hours
honey but I was yes but I had like Idol
a there on my mom because my hair was so
big and I was on like row six I didn't
want the people behind me I was like oh
Lord
mrs. Warner Brothers City and I don't
want to make them upset so I literally
was leaned over the whole time but it
was really really really fun to see
people respond to those things and
you're not just credited as shangela in
those end credits
you are DJ shangela period full name yes
why was that important for you to not
just be shangela well it's very
important to me because a lot of times
as drag entertainers people start to see
us only as a drag entertainer and I want
people as well as remember that I work
as an actor I've been working in small
guest star role some things like two
Broke Girls and glee and community I'd
be down an alien with my purse on the
x-files The Mentalist bones you know
I've been on in a lot of things and I
and I hope to be it more but I want
people to know that I'm a versatile
actor as well I love that remember you
guys can drop your questions for
shangela in the console or I will get
them here rain Dre wants to know who's
your celebrity crush and what was it
like working with everyone on set well -
for one I like that it's like Papa's
combo I like that okay hey rain okay so
my celebrity crush would have to be well
I've always been a Hugh
fan and in love with Will Smith Jada
don't kill me I love you too Jada I love
you Jada but you know Will Smith it just
is such an amazing actor and also his
personality is so fun you just feel like
I can hang out with him all day
have a great time hey wheel and how is
it on set with Gaga was just phenomenal
it was a dream come true
I mean you I would tell her like I got
to entertain her and she'd say Oh shad
and she's at Richie listen to shad and
it was so much fun so great pretty
incredible you said you want to do a lot
more what's still on the career bucket
list things you want to check off oh I
want to work with some amazing writers
and people like lean away who I know I
think she's phenomenal in our community
and she does great work Shonda Rhimes I
mean I'm a scandal how to get away with
murder kind of girl okay
and I just feel like there's so many
great stories that could be told as well
in addition to the ones that are already
out there I would love to be a part of
that amazing storytelling you know you
know I want to be like Olivia Pope you
know with the jacket and the hair to the
side coming into my his handle the ass
Kenneth Clark wants to know do you ever
think of an actor actress that maybe you
want to work with well work with again
would be Jennifer Lewis and you know we
had it was your mentor it is true for we
had a four-part series called Jennifer
Lewis and shangela on YouTube that
people can still find you can still find
all episodes and I'd really you know
she's so great on black she's busy right
now but I'm hoping to in 2019 come back
together and revive some of that
experiences we have a great time
together and she even helped me to
prepare for the audition for this role
and now she always tells me also your
big movie star now mm-hmm well don't
forget about those who helped you to get
to where you are that's a line from
what's love got to do with you you have
that impression down pat oh well I've
lived in that impressions basement for
eight years so I I love Jen so much and
to be I was her on the snatch game you
know a drag race just to be able to have
that friendship and she's like my la mom
and she's like a mentor but I honor her
so much because she had really knows how
to stay grounded in a world you know
entertainment where it's like who here
today gone tomorrow kind of thing so I
watched I learned so much from her has
she asked for 10%
waiting waiting she said your rents
going up or your things about the street
when you come home I'm like okay
write the check the last time you were
here was in the middle of all stars we
didn't know the outcome of all stars
then you didn't win a lot of people were
upset you didn't win have what was it
like to process that one because you
knew for a long time that outcome was
and then you had to sit on it and then
it comes out in the world hears about it
what was it like to then process that
all for a second time um I think that
when I first went through it when we
filmed the show it was very shocking I
was very I was devastated I was sad
because I really felt like gosh you know
I worked so hard to get up into this
moment and I just really just wanted an
opportunity to lip-synch at the end
that's all I was ready you know the song
was wrecking ball honey I was the
wrecking balls up in there okay I was
really excited and to have that moment
to not be awarded that moment that
really hurt when I felt like I had a
good shot at it based on my run but you
know what I learned is that you can't be
in charge of who's gonna support you is
gonna vote for you how things are gonna
turn out in life you just got to know
how to ride the wave keep a positive
attitude and keep working and that's
what I did i remediate Lee went back to
work and then when people got to
experience it you know when it happened
in March of this year I was like okay so
let's see how they're gonna respond and
honestly people have been so like they
also share that they were upset in no
shade at all to anyone in the top four
including Trixie the winner because I
felt like everyone the top four worked
so hard to get there they deserved those
moments and she deserves where she is
but my fans and people who supported me
that season felt like oh we hurt for you
but at the same time they never gave up
on me and I never gave up on me and I
hope to inspire people that when things
don't go your way in one particular
moment that doesn't mean you get to do
okay poor me and you just sit down in
wall away no honey you get up you keep
moving you see the doll is on a 181 city
tour this year which is the largest
largest single person drag race tour
from any contestant in history hey I've
worked on six continents I'm continuing
to do amazing great things and I'm in
this
which tells has such a great LGBTQ kind
of connection as well to be able to
represent that on screen in this moment
now it says you know what don't give up
on the dreams I came from Paris Texas
used to watch airplanes go over my
grandma's house going one day I hope to
ride on those now that's probably all
the place I get to sleep right now
you're like I wish I wasn't on so many
air I'm Delta diamond fish you know yes
uh well Trixie was here not that long
ago yeah and talked about the ending of
all starts three and I want you to take
a look at it Oh a surprise yes
everybody was team Trixie team shangela
and then when it wasn't shangela top two
they were team nobody yes it's kind of
odd in that way very odd but um I did
that damn things I have like zero
regrets yeah also in the episode I was I
was like I'm they said who should be in
the top with you and I said Chancellor
she's amazing right to this day I'm like
ash Angela super fan I'm the girl in the
front yes queening her so however I
can't give her my crown sceptre any my
money and nor should you
yeah that's right it's Angela's she'll
just come up tomorrow and drag-race
she'll pop out of a box when we find so
she can't give you her crown sceptre our
money she said oh yeah that's alright
she can give me one of those pairs of
lashes no cuz she wear like 96 yes your
eyes there but I love it's because I
think there is this whole kind of
negative side to the fandom sometimes of
people are like she was robbed or
so-and-so doesn't deserve this but it
everything happens the way it was
supposed to happen for a reason yeah as
long as you continue working you know
you it's part of it as your individual
responsibility to not get caught up in
all the occasional drama from online I
remember on season three you know I just
been doing direct for a year there were
times that skills of mine like makeup
and creating things had to catch up to
who I was entertainer I got called
booger and told I didn't belong there I
belong on other seasons which I showed
up on those two honestly you know it's
all about you just had to continue
believing in yourself and I think she
has a strong belief in herself and I
appreciate her say she's a fan of mine
I've seen her in the front row and I'm
like yes now tip me home
she said she thinks you will pop out of
a box again on drag race would you ever
go back and compete again well you know
what I have such a great relationship
with RuPaul's Drag Race and I love
RuPaul so much of course you know they
call you never know where I'll pop up
I'm shangela now I'm a little
shell-shocked or shangela is shook my
new comedy show is called but for this
year but who knows you never know why
I'll pop up and I love the show I love
what a great opportunity it's given to
so many Queens so many drag queens are
so easy without they're doing amazing
things weather around the world are just
locally in their own bar so hallelu and
you never know you never know all right
let's get to some of these fan questions
okay hey um Joe wanted to know if you
would pop out of a box against we've
answered that but also says love you
keep on working Thank You Louise wants
to know who is your biggest influence
and why you know my biggest influence
besides Jennifer I already talked about
Beyonce as well Beyonce and Lady gaga
and I'll tell you why Beyonce because I
recently saw the on the run tour as well
the newest one and every time like this
is someone who like kills it kills it
and you think okay tonight you could
take a break if you wanted to every time
I've seen her a hundred and ten percent
this woman can fall down a flight of
stairs get her hair caught in a fan
snatch back she ain't stop and she is
unstoppable and I love the fact that she
has so much heart but she's also so so
smart and and just a well-rounded
entertainer someone that you know if you
go you can be like honey no matter what
the ticket cost was I got my money's
worth and that's what I feel about
Gaga's well I've seen every concert tour
before I was even in a film was not as a
fan first you know and to see that she
can dive into so many different avenues
I want to be like that too I hope to
continue to work in a lot of different
ways people try to put you in this one
box okay you're a singer you know you're
a dancer you're a drag queen but even
Gaga's been like an actor she's killed
that she had the jazz album she comes
out with the concert tour she says oh
superball got you let's do it you know I
love that so I hope to continue to work
and explore so many other different
things too I can't wait to watch what
you do next well thank you I'm coming
back yes you're never gonna think you're
ever going away you're gonna keep
popping out surprising us Kenneth wants
to know if you've seen any of the
all-star four rumors and what
you think of the supposed contestant oh
well I try to stay off of getting any
spoilers because you know like I said of
the show I'm a fan I've seen every
season every episode honey I've seen
every untucked every extra lap I really
enjoy the show so I don't like even want
to tell me anything but I will say that
I'm sure there's gonna be drama twists
and turns trust me and out my advice to
any of them is if anyone gets eliminated
lock the doors okay don't let him come
back here no more flicking the light
back guys go behind the screen to wrap
things up here shangela calm is where we
can go to get tickets for the tour right
yes you can find out the dates where I'm
going to be in the locations tickets
even change little comments well as some
great new merchandise and products you
know I'm never too far away from
halle-loo fans yeah but it's great stuff
and I just hope that people continue to
be inspired to keep going for whatever
they want in their world you know
whatever dream or passion you have
because look tada
Here I am stop and girl no I love it
alright so go to shangela come get your
tickets 180 181 cities and I'm gonna
take on a nap in 2019 it's gonna say
2019 see a little less of shangela I
just love that it's 181 not 180 and if
you haven't go see a stars board out in
theaters right now it's a really great
film and you will laugh your ass off at
her and Willem and the soundtrack don't
forget this down yet it's sickening
number one right now watch I don't maybe
get to go on there you need to pull a
share into a cover album of all this
stars born don't play I might get
blacklisted by lady gaga for doing all
that but I'm gonna have to do it
something you know I'm actually on the
album you can hear me I believe it's on
track for the intro to the lobby on rose
wow that's me that's me oh yeah just
like some Michelle visage from the
bodyguard soundtrack okay you can always
be I'm number four on that sound
halle-loo alright well thank you so much
shangela and thank you guys for watching
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you